僕は1回を使ったことないんですけど youtube でよくリスナーという言葉を
聞きます
ディズナとリッスン約1でリスナーと言います
youtube って
耳だけじゃねえだろヘッド耳と心で youtube 幹事様や
肇社長ですこれやっぱって受けて今年もは気になってしまいました
みてください僕の髪型釜山なんとしたいというわけで今日は僕の髪の毛は何とかしよう
と思います実はですね僕明日ちょっとイベントあるので by baby 宮田が来て
くれるのでまぁそれでにねちょっとオリジナリティ溢れてというか泊をどうやって切っ
てくれるんだった楽しんでほしいので僕は時に行くパフォーマンスと
できることはないので髪型だけでも誰もしますよと思います行くぞ
今年はね最初アクターになったんですけど途中からずっとこういう感じの色でなんかゆ
るーく行ってきたのでねまつげでパチンと音ちょっと基板な壁が薄いと思いますよ
エナジー bleach
うんうんというわけでこれぐらい部でも外でやっ気分まで暗くもないんですよ
今これじゃないから全然ここらへんまで明るくなります
髪の毛を黄色にしてから色を入れますどんな色それがちょっとに孫楽しみにというわけ
で須磨区神岳の色ず市場を全部話はそこからだ
よしやるぞおっけーっ
した時縫いますなんか月くらいから the chaos 転じたですね
あああ
ああああああ
なぁよしこれでしばらく放置したの金髪になります
でわー
いやーこれからですよこれからですからねこれが出て僕のか見方が変わるのはてず
kinky マッチん気になったのでここに色をつけていきますこれを使ってな
これは何かといってもばれちゃうんでこのエラーを入れて僕は今日
イベントに行ってきますなに今までにない色ですからきっと来てくださった皆さんも
楽しんでくれることでしょう
きっと大好評間違いないじゃ早速色入れて
ですいいじゃん
みんなおろしだっ
[音楽]
ハイテクで完成しましたちょっとまだねほんと見た瞬間のインパクトは大体のでこんな
カービン方ちょっとまだ見せないですよ
もうこの方々撤去はイベントに入ってくれると思いますパンの皆様に感謝を込めて
みんなを笑顔にさせていきたいとおもいます
ではいってきます
[音楽]
rar
me
ni
re ああああ
hasan a
me
teame
car
me
はい取り上げてこんな髪型にしてみましたーこっちがガーターでこっちが青でござい
ます太陽と月のイメージでございますポケットもスターサン&ムーンぜひ遊んでみて
ください
あっ攻めじゃないよ
どうしよう後ろどうなってるのかなっ
ん2
どうなってますぼく適当に行ったり後ろわからないんだよ
どうなってました